zum Glück habe ich nicht auf die Kamera
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute geht es endlich mal wieder eine
einfache Torte eine Torte die schön
schokoladig und nussig schmeckt mit
einer Fruchtfüllung und einer Creme oben
drauf und auf diese Torte freue ich mich
schon ziemlich lange haselnussböden
Schokolade Kirsche Vanillecreme top
wirklich die perfekte Torte jetzt für
die Jahreszeit ich zeig euch mal die
Zutaten für den Teig dafür verwende ich
150 g weiche Butter 150 g Zucker etwas
Salz und Tonka Paste drei Eier 200 g
Haselnüsse die werden gleich noch
gemahlen 100 g Mehl und einen Teelöffel
Backpulver oder ihr nehmt gerne das
backmehl einen Esslöffel Kakao und 50 g
gehackte und geröstete Haselnüsse gebt
ihr zuerst die Butter mit dem Zucker
Salz und der Tonka Paste in die
Rührschüssel und verrührt alles schön
geschmeidig ich bin voll schön
so jetzt passt jetzt passt das Rezept
auch zum rührelement denn der
Schneebesen ist nur für flüssige Teige
gedacht für Eischnee für Sahne und eben
wenn man mal Eier mit dem Zucker
verrühren will aber ansonsten ist der
Schneebesen nicht dafür geeignet jetzt
Zucker Salz und Tonka rein und alles
schön cremig rühren
bei uns hier drin ist die Heizung
ausgewiesen jetzt haben wir sie an aber
hier drin ist alles kalt sogar die
Butter mit kalt beim Rühren deswegen
mache ich jetzt bisschen warm
[Musik]
jetzt ist die Masse schön weiß cremig
und ich kann die Eier einzeln dazugeben
und für etwa eine halbe Minute einrühren
[Musik]
perfekt und jetzt gebe ich einfach noch
die trockenen Zutaten dazu ich habe
irgendwie vergessen Flüssigkeit mit
abzuwägen es kann sein dass ich ein
bisschen Flüssigkeit brauche ihr könnt
jetzt entweder Kaffee dazu geben in Form
von Espresso ihr könnten Likör dazugeben
ihr könnt Buttermilch oder Milch
dazugeben alles was ihr möchtet der Teig
sollte dann nämlich nicht zu fest sein
und deswegen werde ich jetzt gleich noch
was brauchen und dann kommt es hier auf
den Boden
dann habe ich nämlich einen Crunch Boden
[Applaus]
und ich mache uns jetzt einen Kaffee da
rein
ja
den rühre ich jetzt hier rein ganz
langsam und vorsichtig und vor allem
wenn Mehl dabei ist nicht mehr so viel
rühren sondern nur alles kurz verrühren
bitte sei nicht so klein durch
[Musik]
dann fülle ich das jetzt hier rein alles
wird schön glatt gestrichen und der
Kuchen kann bereits gebacken werden
ich bin bei Let's Dance dabei und am 17
februar geht's los
ich brauche Unterstützung
perfekt
reicht für heute weiter geht's mit dem
Backen für die Kirschfüllung verwende
ich ein Glas Kirschen mit dem Saft darin
60 Gramm Stärke 50 Gramm Zucker und
etwas zitronenpaste
nehmt ihr einfach das Glas
kippt ein bisschen Flüssigkeit hier rein
dann rührt ihr die Stärke ein
dann auch den Zucker
jetzt dürft ihr das Ganze aufkochen
lassen
gern auch schon etwas zitronenpaste
dazugeben
ich kann jetzt hier beim Einkochen auch
schon die Kirschen dazugeben
[Musik]
und da ist fast eingefroren aber es ist
okay für die Torte das macht jetzt gar
nichts
und wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr den sogar
noch trinken mit Likör zum Beispiel oder
einem Kaffee aber muss nicht sein und
jetzt kommt hier die Kirschmasse drauf
noch schön warm
damit sie darauf dann fest wird
aber ich will das ein bisschen naked
cake mäßig machen deswegen nicht bis zum
Rand aber wenn ihr so einen sauberen
Rand haben wollt lasst ihr den Ring drum
und streicht es bis zum Rand dann könnt
ihr so einen sauberen Abschluss haben
sieht schon mal super aus das lasse ich
jetzt noch mal abkühlen am besten
draußen auf der Terrasse und in der
Zwischenzeit kann ich schon die Creme
machen dann sind wir gleich fertig
[Musik]
für die Creme verwende ich 250 Gramm
Quark 50 Gramm Puderzucker
Vanilleextrakt 200g Sahne und sanaparte
zum steif schlagen der Quark wird es mit
Puderzucker Vanilleextrakt verrührt
dann könnt ihr die Sahne langsam zu
gießen und mit San apart die Creme steif
schlagen also ziemlich schnell die Creme
stelle ich so lange in den Kühlschrank
bis der Kuchen komplett abgekühlt ist
dann setzt ihr den Kuchen auf eine
Tortenplatte
muss echt sagen dass wir früher wir
hatten nicht so Tortenplatten ich weiß
nur wir hatten eine Glasplatte aber
meine Mama hat Kuchen und Torten
trotzdem immer in so komischen
kuchenglocken angeboten
und ich fand es immer nicht so schön als
Kind und als Teenie schon deswegen ist
mir jetzt immer wichtig dass eine Torte
die gebacken ist und mit viel Liebe
gebacken ist eben auch schon präsentiert
wird ich könnte jetzt nicht einfach auf
den tortenretter anbieten das bringe ich
nicht übers Herz denn das Auge ist mit
jetzt kommt die Sahne da drauf
ihr könnt es natürlich mit dem
Spritzbeutel auftragen oder einfach so
wie so ein Wölkchen
eine schöne wolkenhaube machen
[Musik]
dann wird die Torte jetzt fertig
dekoriert ich habe hier etwas Kakao und
damit jetzt nicht so viel Kakao auf
einmal auf die Torte kommt habe ich hier
noch Reis drin trockenen Reis ich habe
das ganze auch mal beschriftet als Kakao
Reis dann habe ich jetzt immer da und
kann den Reis eben immer weiter benutzen
muss sie nicht wegschmeißen da ein
bisschen Zimt rein
[Musik]
jetzt noch ein bisschen
Zartbitterschokolade drüber raspeln und
fertig
[Musik]
dann kann die Torte jetzt probiert
werden sie ist jetzt auch schön
durchgezogen stand jetzt noch eine
Stunde im Kühlschrank und ich glaube
Murat freut sich schon alle Vorsätze des
neuen Jahres gegenüber
aber du kannst dich ja sportlich
betätigen du kannst ja
du kannst dich ja sonst gesund ernähren
natürlich ich heiße auch gerade nur
Gemüse ich bin gerade richtig auf dem
sieht toll aus ich finde es erinnert so
ein bisschen davon was auch inspiriert
an die feuerwehrtorte und das ist für
mich so ein typischer Sonntag
nachmittagskuchen ja Sonntag nachmittags
Freunde kommen genau Freunde kommen
nicht die Schwiegereltern Freunde kommen
und man grillt und und vielleicht
einfach das Stück wegnehmen
cool wirklich ganz schön ich mag das
wenn ein Torten so feucht sind
hier Anna ich sehe doch schon dass du es
auch
lecker
genieße es langsam
coole Kuchen ich mag den Quark in der
Creme genau
falls ihr keine Haselnüsse mögt oder
nicht vertragt dann könnt ihr auch
Mandeln nehmen komplett weglassen ist
schwierig weil dann wäre es einfach nur
ein Rührteig dann könnte auch normalen
Rührkuchen machen ich finde die
Haselnüsse geben schon besonderen
Geschmack ab aber Mandeln
ja ist langsam alles gut du musst das
ist kein Kuchen wird essen
Kuchen genießen mach's gut ich gehe
rüber mach's gut bis zum nächsten Mal
und wenn ihr gerne weitere solche
einfache Kreationen sehen wollt dann
schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
tschüss
[Musik]